you have so much going on right now it's
incredible it's incredible it's been
lean times early on in your crew and you
thought will I ever work now that's all
you do you know yeah yeah I think
everybody kind of you know if you're if
you're lucky you know you kind of have
these cycles like herbs and flows yeah
in one's career and yeah this is this is
kind of flowing right yeah I just listed
45 things that you were in that are all
happening right now plus you have your
own lunchbox I'm told I want to ask you
about one of it one of your projects
because there's so many to talk about
but righteous gemstones getting a lot of
love from people people really love that
show character yeah you're such a
terrific actor I'm drawn to your
character baby Billy for many reasons
but the hair for obvious reasons
the hair of that character hypnotizes me
let's take a look I just yeah I love
that that insane papa Dory I mean like
if we maybe we all get there you know if
we're lucky enough to have to be silver
foxes yeah yeah yeah I just like the
height you get with that you know it's
funny because like Danny when he asked
me to do this show it was like towards
the end of Vice Principals yeah and he
he said look I want you to do this other
thing he said but I wanted to be a
different configuration I want you to
play 70 year old man I said what right
what right I said yeah and so we had a
really good friend of mine a guy named
Jake Garber who was Quentin's guy come
down and he had like 45 minutes to put
this together and and we just kind of
did is the first wig we put on we walked
out and that was it
that's pretty good I can look 70 years
old by just getting like only six hours
I mean I look at myself sometimes when I
get up in the morning and I'm an 82 year
old man yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not I'm
not far behind you man yeah behind you
yeah no no you were far far behind do
you get do you get recognized for that
role a lot to people recognize because
you've done so many things so they
recognized you for a baby Billy they
recognize you from Vice Principals what
are they recognize you for yeah yeah you
know kind of like kind of all over the
map really but yeah with with baby you
know I get a lot of BBF right baby Billy
Freeman are a little
or like or like baby bee or I never get
walton I never I never get that I mean
I'll get like a magical animal like the
unicorn yeah yeah like like now I'm a
horse right you know yeah yeah but I get
I get hey [ __ ] that's what I get a
lot it's always me yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's but it's yeah it's interesting
life like everybody kind of responded to
it we had we had such a good time kind
of making it and just had no idea that
this would kind of be the response to it
did you you did it I it looked to me
like you did full frontal nudity in this
character was that that would first of
all hats off to you for doing that every
day I did I had a DD right victim yeah
yeah a dick double okay wait you can get
a dick double you could get a dick
double you could actually know that is a
possibility it was a possibility but I
want one in life yeah okay the
production says like look at your dick
and go boom man yeah no and if curious
how does this happen you know that's got
to be full frontal and did they suggest
well well because because it's you know
I have like an 80 year old a 70 year old
man's body right so it really kind of
came down to that and and and so they
they found this I found this guy you
know that was yeah it was great guys a
great with a 70 year old body yeah but
then you know he was an 80 year old he
was an 80 year old plays a very
good-looking man he's a wonderful very
good-looking man yeah and they so we did
it he was the he was my body double
right and when we saw that scene we're
looking at his penis yeah yes yes
Conan you're looking at his penis are
you thinking about my Peter eyes the
wrong penis yeah oh the but but I got a
when the show was kind of coming out of
a critic friend of mine got it before
you know everybody else does it critic
gets things when they send them out for
review right and and she called me and
she said hey you know III really I love
I love this show I got really loved it
and more importantly wow you look great
you know you've been working out I saw
your body like in that like your whole
body in that and that scene and I'm
thinking wait a minute
that's an eighty-year-old stand-in body
my body looks better than that are you
are you kidding me yeah I don't know I
have to see that I mean they I don't
know I I don't have you ever had to do
full frontal and oh god no no I know I
deep body shame I've had I've worn
things where it looks like I'm naked
yeah but I've never actually had
everything on full display everything on
or will that ever happen nor does
anybody want that to happen so I well I
I personally have I have no shame with
it I mean I will let it all hang out for
me I don't I don't I don't care
good for you it is kind of is where it
is and you you were naked once in a play
well yeah I I did this play out here
when I first kind of came out here and I
was a young man now and I am I'm from
Georgia and not that all people from
Georgia are bashful but I happen to be
one of them yeah and and and it was this
artist by the name of Aegon Sheila and I
had to to be on he was on stage naked
for her half the play and and I'll never
forget like the very first time I had
this robe on and it kind of swung kind
of you know open and and you could see
wow that's just that a penis standing I
don't know what's right there but to ask
you yeah yeah that's right you got a
problem but it's so the point in the
play was kind of coming up where where I
had to take this robe off and I and I
knew it was coming up and I got so
embarrassed by I was like overcome with
anxiety and and can I stand yeah yeah
yeah I had it I had it on and I threw it
off and I had to walk across the stage
and all of a sudden like oh my god I'm
nude in front of like 99 people oh my
god what am I gonna do and so I walk
like walk
across the stage like like this say my
stuff you know my lines and and of
course he likes worse you know don't cut
to like a week later a week later is
coming up I take the robe off I walk out
like this yeah like what's going on I
had no problem with her get a would
comfortable with your body yeah yeah I
would not never get to that stage but
I'm glad you did
glad you got there